colleges
and they say his name
there's it's so impersonal
so i try to anchor it in
reality
so i go like for instance you that's how
i was bringing you on stage right
which is not
really from far from the realm of
possibility from what i hear
true it is right
it is okay i like a challenge yeah we'll
bring him up now so i'd say um
i'll say you know he's done my podcast
um
you know we met in vegas while he was on
a tv show right and we had a good time
and then he ignored me for three years
like i would probably say something like
that just as a joke right no but
seriously dude he's like the nicest guy
so [ __ ] funny he has a podcast called
the dollop
and i think that alone people will be
like there's personal
something personal
it's the worst one like i mean i i have
to say and i'm just going to say it
before mark maron was marc maron
i have to say he gave the worst interest
[Laughter]
known really
i like like
his resentment
would come out as far as having to do
that part of the show no his resentment
toward whoever was now oh really yeah oh
god this guy you know dances around on
stage with his high energy
to get a lap but he's not tricking
anybody
bobby lee and then you're you walk up on
stage and you have to always kind of
whisper like what the [ __ ]
you know and he's like hey man being
real
[Laughter]
and i heard i heard that i had heard
that
somebody
somebody had
confronted him
right going hey dude if you give me down
the [ __ ] [ __ ] smash your head and
they stop but then
once you know me he deserved what he got
which is like
the respect that he deserved
right yeah he does he's number one i'm
going to give mark maron every
compliment in the book right now right
is number one
i i don't think that there be modern-day
podcasting without wtf that's number one
number two
when i um
have serious problems with
either other comics or
career decisions and choices i always go
to him and he gives me the best advice
yeah number three
i love the man i think that um
he's one of those guys when he was in
the joker
and i saw him i i almost welled up in
tears
i'm being real going
ah i think good for him yeah when he got
barack obama on his podcast i was like
obviously obviously you know what i mean
yeah like he's the [ __ ] yeah so when i
tell that's what i told you this should
be how you bring him up on stage next
time
yeah no i do do that yeah yeah when i
bring him on
you know i mean like he's the [ __ ] so
you know that's i'm giving it so i don't
want people to like listen to what he
used to do 15 years ago and give shitty
intros because i know what's going to
happen they're going to [ __ ] go to
mark and go oh yeah people don't dig up
old stuff on people and come at them
what year is this
yeah you're right his show is his show's
actually one because the guy did the
dollop with dave was a writer on his
show and was on it a bunch and so i was
on it very quickly
and that's another one well they'll be
like from ifc's marin and i'm like
literally two lines literally in the
background once and then two lines yeah
11 from marin was he nice on the set he
was actually so [ __ ] nice yeah yeah
he's always been really really cool to
me cause he knows dave but no he was
like he like drove me to set and he was
just really really cool yeah yeah i love
the man so do i and he's and like you
said i mean i do think it is like i
remember i've known about mark maron for
the whole time i've known about comedy
in my life you know not to make him feel
like old but like he is he started so
young yeah he was on like comedy central
when i was you know
a kid and so it's like you know there is
there is you have many of those moments
in this business as gutting as it is at
times where you you have these crossover
moments you go [ __ ] if i told myself
that
that would be worth it you know you're
gonna make me cry give it to me baby no
i'm not gonna touch you oh i'm sorry oh
no but you you hit something
in the head right there
you're absolutely right there are there
are instances
right
incidences yeah you got it i want to
keep repeating i got it right i would do
it one more time
in my life where
i look around and i go if i would have
told
my 23 year old self
when i was first signed up for open mic
go these are the kind of things you're
going to be doing 30 years from now
right that kid would not believe it
totally and it's like
and i think that deep down inside when
we were first starting
right moved to la whatever right